IN WHICH CLARENCE DARROW
ASKED SCIENTISTS TO EXPLAIN
THE THEORY OF EVOLUTION.
BUT THE JUDGE
IN THE SCOPES MONKEY TRIAL
WAS JOHN RAULSTON,
AND HE BELIEVED...
- I HAVE BEEN CALLED ON
BY GOD
TO BE THE JUDGE
IN THIS CASE.
SO I DON'T CARE WHAT ALL
THESE SCIENTISTS HAVE TO SAY.
THEY CAN'T GIVE TESTIMONY.
- SO CLARENCE DARROW DECIDED...
- OKAY, ALL OF MY WITNESSES,
THEY CAN'T GIVE TESTIMONY,
SO I'LL ASK SOMEONE
WHO'S AN EXPERT ON THE BIBLE
TO GIVE THE TESTIMONY.
HEY...
[laughs]
WHAT WAS YOUR NAME? BRYAN.
I KNOW YOU'RE ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS CASE,
BUT WHY DON'T YOU GO
ON THE WITNESS STAND,
AND I'LL QUESTION YOU
ABOUT THE BIBLE.
- NOW, WILLIAMS JENNING BRYAN
WAS SO EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
HE WAS, LIKE...
- OH, MY GOD.
I'M GONNA DESTROY YOU
AS A WITNESS.
I WILL GO
ON THE WITNESS STAND.
- NOW, THE JUDGE DIDN'T WANT HIM
TO DO THIS.
THE JUDGE WAS PRESI--
PRESIDENTIAL.
[laughs]
[laughing]
WHEN CLARENCE DARROW PUTS
WILLIAM JENNINGS BRYAN
ON THE BIBLE, HE ASKS...
- DO YOU BELIEVE ALL THE STORIES
OF THE BIBLE LITERALLY?
- AND THE FIRST ANSWER
OF WILLIAMS JENNING BRYAN IS...
- YES. THE BIBLE IS LITERAL.
I BELIEVE IN IT LITERALLY.
- AND THEN, ASKING HIM
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS...
- WHERE DID CAIN'S WIFE
COME FROM?
HE MADE ADAM AND EVE,
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE,
AND CAIN FINDS A WIFE.
WHERE DID--
WHERE DID CAIN'S WIFE COME FROM?
- WILLIAMS JENNING BRYAN
GETS FLUSTERED AND SAYS...
- WELL, I--I LEAVE THAT
UP TO YOU AGNOSTICS TO FIND OUT.
- THAT'S ALL CLARENCE DARROW
NEEDED.
- SO YOU'RE NOT INTERPRETING
THE BIBLE LITERALLY.
AND HE GOES ON TO DESTROY
WILLIAMS JENNINGS BRYAN
ON FACTS.
- GREAT.
ARE YOU STILL SPINNING,
OR HOW DO YOU FEEL?
- WELL, I'M...
- I'M DIZZY.
- MM-HMM.
- I FEEL WEIRD.
I FEEL LIKE I THINK I KNOW
WHERE I'M GOING, AND THEN...
- I GET UTTERLY CONFUSED
ABOUT...
- WHERE I THOUGHT
I WAS GOING.
I KNOW...
[laughs]
I'M GONNA GET FACEBOOK
RESPONSES FOR THIS.
- THIS WAS THE COMPLETE
DESTRUCTION
OF WILLIAMS JENNING BRYAN.
AND WILLIAMS JENNING BRYAN
LOOKS LIKE A FOOL.
BUT WILLIAMS JENNING BRYAN
KNOWS...
- I HAVE THE MOST AMAZING
CLOSING ARGUMENT TO MAKE.